This week we headed to Ireland for a little work trip.
It was a series of a lot of flights.
They were very long,
and we were so exhausted by the time we finally got there.
It took us about 36 hours to get to Ireland,
but when we were flying in to the country,
it was all worth it.
The green pastures and the little farms were absolutely breathtaking.
And then we got a rental car.
As you know, they drive on the opposite side of the road here,
so it was a terrifying experience for the first little bit,
but Daniel handled it like a charm.
I definitely did not want to tackle that.
So, so glad Daniel was with me.
Then we stopped for lunch at a little market.
It was so beautiful.
We got tucked into our Airbnb right as the sun was setting,
and the views were absolutely stunning.
Then we all kind of took a little nap.
We were all so tired. The Airbnb kitchen was so cute.
So we got up, it was like five thirty PM at this point.
We drug ourselves to the grocery store,
stocked our fridge with the essentials.
Um, I love how in Europe,
none of the eggs are washed,
and so they keep them, um,
on the shelves and not in the refrigerator.
Then after that, we headed home.
We kind of got lost,
but they finally made it back to Airbnb and they have no idea.
What time it is. But I'm definitely ready for bed.